how's everybody doing how are you Mr
Gourley I'm doing pretty good we haven't
seen each other in a while because
you've been gallivanting and
globetrotting I've been globetrotting
gallivant and out there doing my thing
um yeah I've covered a lot of ground uh
but I'm back he got sick yeah I got a
little sick yeah it's all right it's
just what happens when I travel a lot
um
I uh I always catch a cold when I'm in
the plane a lot and
um some people say it's the Selfies I
love to I will offer a selfie if someone
doesn't even want one oh no yeah I'll be
like hey you you want a selfie what
don't you want us healthy I was a late
night King
what I really there goes all the
dramatic tension yeah I was a late night
late not King
there that's their tension for you
anyway
um yeah so uh if someone has a cold in
any of the places I've been I will catch
it yeah and how about you Sona how are
you I'm good I
I feel like I don't want to say this
because it makes me sound really stupid
but uh you know I live in Altadena and
there's a lot of animals there like and
we have friends down the street these
guys Jeff and Amanda and they're
wonderful and they always warn us if
there's animals when you say animals
coyotes like legit animals peacocks yeah
there's peacocks just chilling on our
streets in our neighborhood too yeah
what is that about I think they're all
from Arcadia in the Arboretum they all
escaped you know what what I you imagine
what do you have the answer is
I don't know if they I they are escaped
from this uh yeah the Arboretum you know
it's funny we have a daughter there and
it stole her grilled cheese well
anyone don't you you know to immediately
accuse a peacock we saw it happen oh you
saw him you saw the peacock do it yeah I
have to say la is a very strange place
because these animals get loose there's
a whole bunch of parrots oh that live in
our neighborhood that clearly they
escaped yeah
um and they're up in the trees and uh
they all know filthy limericks
I'm trying to raise my children
um and uh it's awful it's terrible but
yeah these uh yeah there's very strange
animals roaming around L.A and Altadena
it's a little out there it's out it's up
there it's an elevation that's you live
up the mountain yeah so our neighbor
Jeff texted us and was like a bobcat
headed towards your backyard I love it I
love it I immediately
thought he meant the machine and not the
animal Oh I thought you were gonna say
Bobcat gold plate
so this is why this is stupid but wait a
minute you thought Bobcat meaning this
this the snowmobile what like a pool
excavator wait what are we talking about
this is so stupid what this is why I
didn't want to sell this story is uh
yeah that's I thought that's what he
meant it's a it's just like a snowman I
thought someone rented a little mini
tractor yeah and then was driving it
into her oh my God
but then but then I and I have to pull
this up it's very quick and it's very
easy because it's so stupid but this is
what I thought he was talking about I
thought he was talking about the machine
I'm just gonna search Bobcat because
that's the only I when I heard Bobcat I
thought
uh it's the thing that races around on
the snow Bobcat is that not what Bobcat
is
um
I'm thinking about the machine the
tractor the tractor should we clean this
up then because my thing might be too
confusing no it's we're talking about
that okay all right all right it's nice
for people to see your flaws and foibles
so he tells us that and then he just
went Bobcat just went towards your
backyard and I go a real one because you
still mean a real tractor what if it was
a bobcat riding one of those little
Vehicles oh that would be great yeah and
he looked at you and he winked right at
the camera and went get it it was so
stupid so this whole time he's texting
me warning me about this animal I think
he's talking about the machine so he
goes no Bobcat Goldthwait yes a bobcat
why
why oh Jesus so all this time you could
have been rescuing your twins in the
backyard
from a murdering
wild animal and instead you're going
back and forth like Bobcat real one what
do you mean bobcat goldthwave and
meanwhile in the background
he's like wrapping them up in tortillas
yeah yeah so it was just it went and
then he goes and then I would go why and
he goes maybe Steve Gutenberg was
running around so we're just having two
different conversations it's so stupid
and then I and then it hit me and I go I
thought you meant the machine and I was
like like someone rented a bobcat and
was going to do work in our backyard and
then it hit me and I was like a
bobcat yeah my children are back there
and I just covered them in ham gravy
as he's an old Armenian tradition when
children go out to play alone in the
backyard yeah this is serious business
when we moved into our house we were
inherited two bunnies and they were
killed by Bobcat oh you yeah I think you
and then didn't you make them thing for
them so they would be saved well the
this is sad but the Bobcat took one of
them and we thought it was a coyote so I
coyote proofed their pen by the way the
people that gave us this were the people
that lived there prior and said oh
there's never been an issue well they
had three large dogs so they were
keeping the we done we didn't have those
and so I coyote proofed it and then the
next day the other one was gone wait
what so when you coyote proof something
it doesn't Bobcat proof it no because
Bobcats are actually small they're not
much bigger than a house cat so I made
like a mesh fence that a bobcat could
still get through I didn't know there
were Bobcats I got a call not too long
ago that there was a ram in my backyard
and I was so excited it was a Dodge Ram
and it was doing figure eights it was
it was the realtor and um
we could just keep doing this on and on
I got a call that there was a Segway in
my backyard and I said the scooter and
they said no just the transition between
speech and our guest today
my guest today hold on there's more oh
no there's not you
I had the perfect way in you it
up
foreign